التطورات المتلاحقه في هذه الاثناء هي في
البحر الاحمر حيث قال الناطق باسم جماعه
انصار الله الحوثيين محمد عبد السلام ان
بارجه امريكيه اطلقت النار على طائره
استطلاع تابعه للقوات البحريه اليمنيه في
البحر الاحمر واضاف ان الصواريخ التي
اطلقتها البارجه الامريكيه نحو الطائره
اليمنيه انفجر احدها بالقرب من سفينه
جابونيه بالبحر الاحمر واتهم عبد السلام
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وشركائها
بتهديد الملاحه البحريه الدوليه بسبب ما
سماه عسكره البحر الاحمر وتوفير خدمه لسفن
الكيان الصهيوني محذرا من ان يتحول البحر
الاحمر الى ساحه مشتعله اذا استمرت امريكا
وحلفاؤها على النحو الذي هم عليه من
البلطجه حسب تعبيره ودعى الناطق باسم
جماعه الحوث الدول المشاطئة بحر الاحمر
دعاها ان تدرك ما سماه المخاطر التي تهدد
امنها القومي حسب
قوله نقلت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز عن مسؤولين
في الاداره الامريكيه قولهم ان القرار بشن
الولايات المتحده ضربه عسكريه ضد جماعه
انصار الله الحوثيين لم يتخذ بعد واوضح
المسؤولون ان الاسباب تعود الى قل
الولايات المتحده من تعطيل الهدنه الهشه
بين انصار الله الحوثيين والسعوديه اضافه
الى خشيتها من تحول الحرب في غزه الى صراع
اقليمي
اوسع قال مسؤول ايراني للجزيره انه تم
ابلاغ واشنطن بان ايران ليست اطفائي حرائق
ولا تصدر اوامر لحلفائها في محور المقاومه
واضاف ان اتهامات اسرائيل لطهران باستهداف
السفن في المياه الدوليه عبر المسيرات كذب
وهدفها سياسي واوضح ان اي تحرك اسرائيلي
يهدد الامن القومي الايراني في الممرات
المائيه الدوليه سيقابل برد غير متوقع
واضاف ان عمليات انصار الله في باب المندب
نتيجه للموقف الامريكي الداعم بالكامل
لاسرائيل
محملا واشنطن مسؤوليه اي تصعيد قادم في
المياه
الدوليه مره اخرى مشاهدينا نذكر
بالخبر العاجل حيث قال الناطق باسم جماعه
انصار الله الحوثيين محمد عبد السلام ان
بارجه امريكيه اطلقت النار على طائره
استطلاع تابعه للقوات البحريه اليمنيه في
البحر الاحمر واضاف ان الصواريخ التي
اطلقتها البارجه الامريكيه نحو الطائره
اليمنيه انفجر احدها بالقرب من سفينه
جابونيه بالبحر الاحمر عبد السلام اتهم
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وشركائها
بتهديد الملاحه البحريه الدوليه بسبب ما
سماه عسكره البحر الاحمر وتوفير خدمه لسفن
الكيان الصهيوني محذرا من ان يتحول البحر
الاحمر الى ساحه مشتعله اذا استمرت امريكا
وحلفائها على النحو الذي هم عليه من
البلطجه حسب تعبيره ودعى الناطق باسم
جماعه الحوثي الدول
المشاطئة هذا التطور لافت على
صعيد المواجهه اذا صح التعبير في البحر
الاحمر ماذا في التفاصيل ايضا التي تقدمها
صنعاء لما جرى
اليوم لازال هناك لي هناك بيان رسمي من
الناطق العسكري من قبل جماعه الانصار
البيين فنحن بانتظار اي تصريح يؤكد
العمليه وعمليه اسقاط هذه الطائره
الاستطلاع منذ البارحه هناك ا ا من ثلاث
عمليات حصلت في البحر الاحمر
و ونحن ايضا نا في انتظار تاكيدات الناطق
العسكري باسم جماعه انصار الله ليتحدث عن
تفاصيل هذه العمليات و وما كان المستهدف
منها فيما المصادر الملاحيه تؤكد انه تم
تحدير ما يقال تار سف منذ البارحه خلال 2
ساعه لعدم المرور والمضيف ضما بتجاه
الموانع الاسرائيليه
لازالت لازالت هذه العمليات جاريه ويؤكد
انصار الله بانهم مستمرون في عمليتهم
التحذيريه والتي تستهدف السفن الهبه او
المتجهه نحو الموانئ الاسرائيليه وانهم
مكدونس
وتصميمهم للوقوف بجانب اخوانهم في غزه حتى
ينتهي العدوان الاسرائيلي ويرفع الحصار
عليهم فيما يؤكد ايضا ال وزير الدفاع بان
اي عمليه او محاوله من قبل القوات
الامريكيه في ما يمكن عسكره البحر الاحمر
فانهم سيواجهونها ب بقوه اكبر
فطلبه واضح وانه رفع الحصار وادخال الغذاء
والدواء فلا
يستدعي كل ذلك العسكره من قبل الجيش
الامريكي في البحر الاحمر اي ف فهم
يطالبون الدول المشاطه ايضا
بان يتضامنون مع القضيه الفلسطينيه
فمطلبها عادل وهو ادخال الغذاء والدواء
وانهاء العدوان والذي يصفونه بانها حرب
اباده ضد شعب اعزل طيب محمد يعني في في
البدايه لم يكن الصوت واضحا جدا ولكن
كاننا فهمنا منك بانه حتى الان ليست هناك
تفاصيل كبيره بشان ما حصل باستثناء هذا
الموقف ل باسم جماعه الحوثي انصار الله
محمد عبد السلام
صحيح نعم نعم الواضح الان وهو ما تحدث به
المتحدث الرسمي باسم جماعه انصار الله
محمد عبد السلام والذي اكد بان البارجه
الامريكيه اسقطت طائره استطلاع وان صاروخا
اخر جاء بقرب سفينه اخرى جابونيه فنحن
ايضا بانتظار تفاصيل اكثر من المتحدث
والناطق العسكري باسم جماعه ان الله سيعد
هذا الحادث تطورا جديدا في في البحر
الاحمر حيث كانت فقط كما يؤكد المحللون
العسكريون ان انصار الله يحاولون فقط
تحذير واطلاق صواريخ او مسيرات تحذيريه ل
لمنع السفن الاسرائيل السفن الذاهبه الى
الموانئ الاسرائيليه نحن الان نشهد تصعيدا
جديدا قد نشهد
ايضا ت تدخل اكبر من قبل جماعه انصار الله
فيما كان مستوى مستوى تدخلهم فقط للتحرير
وتنبيه السفن الذاهبه الى اسرائيل الان قد
نشهد مواجهه مباشره بين قوات جماعه انصار
الله وايضا القوات الامريكيه هو يعني
لطلما ومنذ بدايه الحرب على غزه كان انصار
الله هم ال المبادرون يعني كانوا هم من
اي
يقطعون الملاحه البحريه ضد السفن التي لها
علاقه باسرائيل هل هذه هي المره الاولى
التي تبادر فيها البحريه الامريكيه او سفن
امريكيه
ب الهجوم او باطلاق سواريخ على طائرات
مسيره حوثيه في البحر
الاحمر ليست المره الاولى التي تطلق سفن
وبوارج امريكيه على طائرات مسيره او
صواريخ فقد سبق وكز الات العسكريه التابعه
لواشنطن بانها اسقطت صواريخ كانت ذاهبه
الى اسرائيل او مسيرات كانت تحوم على
البحر الاحمر لكن هذه المره بعد بعد اعلان
التحالف واعلان امريكا بانها ستضع على حد
تعبيرها حدا ل ما
اسمته بالخطر الحوثي على على السفن في
البحر الاحمر الان ن تطورا جديدا بانه
اعلان مباشر من امريكا ومن واشنطن بعد هذا
الاعلان هي هو اول تدخل واول عمليه اي
مواجهه ممثله مع مع قوات جماعه انصال الله
فنحن الان ن ايضا ربما لاكن دقيقا محمد
يعني اي سؤالي لم يكن مواجهه المسيرات
الحوثيه التي كانت تقول الولايات المتحده
انها تهاجم او تحاول مهاجمه اسرائيل او
الصواريخ التي تطلق باتجاه اسرائيل هذه
المسيره يقول الحوثيون انها كانت تراقب
الملاحه وهذا هو السؤال هل هذه المره
الاولى التي يحصل فيها هذا النوع من
المواجهه بمعنى ان القوات الامريكيه تطلق
صواريخ على مسيره لم تكن متجهه نحو
اسرائيل نعم نعم هذه المره الاولى التي
يتم استهداف واسقاط طائره السيه لم تك
موجهه لاسرائيل او تستهدف اهداف اسرائيليه
فيعد ذلك ايضا انه ان هناك مبادره بالقبل
امريكا بانها عددت الموقف وانها الان بدات
بالمبادره
لمواجهه ما تسميه الخوف وال
الخطر القائم في البحر الاحمر من قبل
جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين فنحن الان قد
نشهد الان تطورا جديدا في المواجهه فكما
قال الحوثي او زعيم جماعه انصار الله
الحوثيين مطالبا الدول المشاطه من البحر
الاحمر من العرب وبدون دون تحالف مع
اسرائيل وان مع امريكا يقول لانه دعونا
نواجه امريكا بشكل مباشر و ودعونا نواجههم
ولا نريد منكم اي مشاركه فقط اصمتوا ولا
تتدخلوا فنحن سنستطيع ان
نواجههم بما لدينا من قدرات وامكانيات
فقال نحن نحن لدينا مبدا او موقف عادل وهو
الوقوف بجانب اخواننا في فلسطين و وليس
مطلبنا او اننا نهجد البحر الاحمر فان
تواجدنا في البحر الاحمر فقط لهذا الهدف
وهو رفع الحصار على غزه فلا فلا نستهدف اي
سفن اخرى لاي دوله اخرى فقط تلك السفن
التي تكون ملاكها الاسرائيليين او تتبع
اسرائيل او تلك التي متجهه الى الموا
الاسرائيليه من صنعاء مراسل الجزيره محمد
العطاب شكرا جزيلا
لك